now the second question about the
genealogies in Matthew and Luke what
exactly do you want me to reconcile be
more specific yeah so we've we've kind
of heard a lot of the attempted
reconciliations right like the levate
marriage and stuff but I want to know in
particular like when you're in
discussions with let's say Muslims or
atheists and stuff like that how what is
your like preferred way number one for
the Muslim I don't answer it I say why
are you attacking the gospels if you
believe Muhammad you guys keep following
the wrong approach
follow the approach that CP myself
employ I'm not saying I'm on cp's
level follow the approach you don't
defend biblical discrepancies to a
Muslim a Muslim because of Muhammad has
to believe my Bible is the perfect
preserved words of God he has to join me
in defending the Bible and affirming it
and reconciling those errors you guys
keep debating the wrong issues and
letting them get away with murder you
must force them to seriously contend
with what Muhammad believed the Bible
you believe in Muhammad you believe what
he says if I show you he said my Bible
is not corrupt it's preserved you got to
stop attacking it but if you attack it
that means you don't believe in Muhammad
so reject and condemn him as a false
prophet then I'll answer your question
so I don't answer the question for them
for the atheist who brings it up my
question for the a atheist would be why
is that relevant to the historicity of
the gospels are you assuming that
documents must be in in erent without
error to be historically reliable you
know you can't assume that because if
that's your Criterion you can't do
history for many things because there
are many sources that we're dependent on
for certain historical events that are
full of discrepancies but no serious
historian discards them a historian will
apply criteria to sift through the
authentic in authentic to arrive at an
accurate portrayal of historical events
so why are you attacking
the gospels on the basis of alleged
discrepancies in the genealogies when
that does nothing to affirm the overall
basic hysteric of the historical Jesus
his claims his death and resurrection
and his appearances to his disciples so
what are you trying to get at with
alleged Bible
discrepancies I see you're following the
wrong
approach because I guarantee you when
you answer the alleged discrepancies
they're going to bring 10 more because
they're not looking for anwers they're
looking to try to cause you to lose
faith I guess on that topic then because
that makes sense I have a question what
do you if you encounter somebody who's
just completely apathetic oh if
someone's asking me as a Christian who
wants to know number one any attempted
harmonization consiliary approach is
simply conjecture what do I mean I don't
have Matthew in front of me and Luke in
front of me so I can't ask them and I
can't read their minds they're with the
Lord
right that's why there are so many
different attempts of harmonizing the
genealogies but the fact that they can
be harmonized shows that there are no
real contradictions because if anyone
harmonization works then the alleged
contradictions dissipate but the problem
is just because you may come up with an
harmonization that works
that concil them right reconciles them
that doesn't mean that harmonization is
correct Because unless Matthew Luke are
here to tell yeah that's right it's
conjecture you get my point that makes
sense so keep these facts in mind a
harmonization is simply that an attempt
to reconcile what appears to be a
discrepancy so if that harmonization
reconciles them then that shows no real
contradictions exist but that
harmonization still may be wrong because
that may not be the way to harmonize it
unless God tells you that's correct it's
simply
conjecture right now in light of all
that the way I reconcile it is very easy
I take Matthew's genealogy to be Joseph
and giving us the legal line but Luke 3
it's not Joseph's it's Mary and let me
give you some proof for it is it a
coincidence that Matthew gives gives you
Joseph's perspective of the anunciation
you're giving Joseph's view of the
anunciation the Incarnation and the role
he played whereas Luke gives you Mary's
perspective is that a coincidence in
Luke it's all from Mary's perspective
what she saw what she heard what she
pondered whereas in Matthew you're not
given Mary's pers perspective you're
given Joseph's perspective what he felt
when he found out Mary was pregnant what
he wanted to do how he reacted how
God comforted him and the role he played
and the revelations so it's Joseph's
perspective
right so because it's Joseph's
perspective it makes sense we're given
Joseph's genealogy especially when it
ends with him being begotten by Jacob
and he had nothing to do siring Jesus
whereas with Luke Luke 1 Luke 2 it's
Mary's perspective so it makes more
sense that Luke 3 is giving you Jesus's
maternal line giving his actual
biological line from his mother but then
why is Joseph mentioned because in
genealogies where there are no male Sons
the husband the
husband will
assume the line of his father-in-law
because he stands in the place of his
father-in-law in case his father-in-law
has no sons and you find find that in
1st Chronicles 2:
34-36
where a man from Judah had no Sons but
daughters and his daughter married his
Egyptian male
servant And that son born to the
Egyptian male servant was accounted to
the
father-in-law not to the Egyptian to
continue the father-in-law's line here
read it for me open up 1 Chronicles chap
2 vers 34-
36 32- 36 read it for me and the sons of
Jada the brother of semi slowly slowly
so we don't go too fast and the sons of
Jada the brother of semi Jeth and
Jonathan and Jeth also died without
children but Jonathan begot fth 1
Chronicles 2
34-36 oh 34 sorry and cesan had no Sons
but daughters and he had what no Sons
but daughters okay and a servant an
Egyptian named jera Jared or
jahi I'm Dey Rams okay that's fine
that's that's why you throw me off it's
okay Jared that's fine and he gave him
his daughter to wife and she bore him
ethi and ethi B begot Nathan and Nathan
begot zad did you see this the grandson
from his daughter continued his line not
the Egyptian
line son
the line is from shishan because it's
talking about the line of this
particular clan of Judah so it's not
talking about the Egyptian it's
mentioning he had no Sons so his
daughter sired a son to continue his ly
for him even though the father was
Egyptian so technically even it's not
necessarily part of the line but it's
going to be genealogically part of the
line yeah because it's still his Grand
son it's still him descendant
biologically through his daughter but
it's not from his son so he's not
continuing his line through a son but
through a daughter and the father
happened to be Egyptian so that son is
not considered Egyptian because you're
supposed to take your father's ethnicity
here because he had no Sons though his
Egyptian male servant fathered his
grandson from his daughter the grandson
was still considered a judahite and
reckoned to his grandfather on his
mother's side because now he's going to
continue his grandfather's line got it
you get it so in the case of Mary Jesus
is truly the biological descendant of
heli
therefore though Joseph is acting in the
place of
Mary the reason why is because he has no
Sons so his son-in-law will be reckoned
in the place of the
genealogy representing Mary's
father okay so the line kind of takes
over at that point because Joseph would
continue the line had he had children
for Mary that's the thing but now the
line of heli heli ends with Jesus
biologically because she had no children
wow but if they had children the
children would be
reckoned for the
father-in-law even though he had no Sons
only a daughter and here's what's ironic
Joseph would represent his line but
nonetheless Joseph did nothing to give
him a son through Mary the Holy Spirit
did and the line still ended with
Jesus got it now someone said but hold
on doesn't Church Traditions
say Mary's father's name was not Ellie
heli it was
Joakim yeah I always get the two names
wrong is it joim or joim I get these for
some reason the im or the I always
confuse believe it's yeah but you know
in English we'd say what so it's an in
yeah believe it's well wait the
tradition says his name was y y Jo
well folks last time I checked people
had two names Matthew Levi Simon Peter
Thomas dimus Solomon
jedah yeah so what he could be joim and
his name can also be Eli in fact you
have a variant of joim
elim joim and there's a
variant El
Aim so El aim is equivalent to joim so
if his name is joim then it's not
surprising he'd be called el short for
elim which is the synonym of
joim right pretty much perfect but my
point being who told you that Eli isn't
also joim Simon Peter Thomas
denus right Matthew
Levi Solomon Jedediah because a lot of
people don't know that Solomon was also
called Jedediah by God in 2 Samuel 12:25
God tells Nathan to name him jedah yedah
Jehovah loves
him so there you go I hope that answered
your question yeah I did thank you